हेलो
एवरीवन एंड वेरी गुड इवनिंग टू
ऑल तो सबसे पहले मुझे यह बता दीजिए सबको
मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है आई एम लाउड एंड
क्लियर
वेरी गुड इवनिंग प्रणय वेरी गुड इवनिंग
प्राग ध्रुव हर हर महादेव गुरु जगत गुरु
जी हाय हेलो आई एम
फाइन वेरी गुड इवनिंग वेरी गुड इवनिंग
ओके थैंक यू थैंक
यू थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं दो मिनट
का ससी एसपी का ओल्ड वीडियोज मैं नहीं दे
सकता आपको आपको टीम से कांटेक्ट करना
चाहिए आप ग्रुप में रहते हो जब भी आपका
बैच बनाया जाता है तो आप उस पर्टिकुलर
ग्रुप के अंदर रहते हो उस ग्रुप में आप
पूछ सकते हो और नितेश सर को पर्सनली टैग
कीजिए ओके अगर आप नए स्टूडेंट हो तो अभी
ज्यादा हमने बेसिक पार्ट कवर कर लिया वैसे
बेसिक कौन सा न्यूमरेशन का और इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग का क्लासेस ज्यादा न्यू हुई है
ड्यूरेशन ज्यादा है थोड़ी सी बट अगर आप
चाहो तो 15 क्लास को कवर कर सकते हो
नेक्स्ट वन वीक के अंदर अंदर क्योंकि अभी
नेक्स्ट जो हम सेक्शन स्टार्ट करने वाले
हैं वह काफी इंटरेस्टिंग सेक्शन होगा और
सबका फेवरेट सेक्शन है वह जो सबको सीखना
है अखिलेश आई एम
फाइन ओके आपने देख ली तो अच्छी बात
है आप अपने रियल नेम से हैं
चंदन वेरी गुड
इवनिंग हेलो साइबर
बॉय अखिलेश वेरी गुड
इवनिंग थोड़ा सा और वेट करते
हैं तो प्लीज अपना नाम बता दीजिए सो दैट
कि मुझे टू नाम से आपको प्रोनाउंस ना करना
पड़े अभी 26 स्टूडेंट्स है तो लीस्ट 40
होने देते हैं तो नेक्स्ट 5 मिनट या ू
मिनट वेट करते हैं देन उसके
बाद बब तक प्रीवियस क्लास से रिलेटेड अगर
आपका कोई डाउट है तो मुझसे पूछ सकते हैं
पप्पू
ओके या आई एम फाइन
आचार्य क्यों एसएमबी एक्सप्लोइटेशन का
क्वेश्चन नंबर फोर नहीं हुआ साइबर बॉय
क्यों नहीं
हुआ
बताइए सोहन राम
राम एक ऑफेंसिव है क्विक टेको सर्विस और
एक डिफेंसिव है शॉक एनालिस्ट डिफेंसिव
पार्ट है और वीपीटी आपका ऑफेंसिव पार्ट
है यह डिफरेंस है
तो आज का जो हमारा सेशन होगा वह बिल्कुल
लास्ट सेशन होगा एन्यूमरेशन पार्ट का तो
आज हम अपना एन्यूमरेशन कंप्लीट कर
देंगे इसलिए मैंने तीन टॉपिक को एक साथ
कवर किया है आज करने वाला हूं तो क्लास
ज्यादा लेंथी नहीं रहेगी क्योंकि आज आप
लोगों से पहले आईम वेरी सॉरी कि आज
प्रॉब्लम यह है कि आज की जो लैब्स है एमएस
एसक्यूएल माय एसक्यूएल और वेब सर्वर की
लैब्स मेरे पास नहीं है हां बट मेरे पास
एक चीटशीट है व चीट शट लाइक आपको
प्रैक्टिकली फील करवाएगी उसमें मैंने आपको
बताया है कि कौन-कौन सी स्क्रिप्ट यूज
करना है कहीं पर मैंने स्क्रीनशॉट अटैच
किया हुआ है तो इसलिए मैं माय एसक्यूएल
माय वेब सर्वर और सॉरी वेब सर्वर और एमएस
एसक्यूएल से रिलेटेड प्रैक्टिक की बजाय
मैं आपके सामने अपनी खुद की एक चिट चट जो
मैंने कहीं प्रीवियस लैब से परफॉर्म करके
बना बनाई हुई है वह आप लोगों के लिए रेडी
की है मेरे पास प्रीमियम लैब्स का कुछ
एक्सेस था बट ड्यू टू पॉलिसीज मैं आपके
सामने उसको एक्सपोज नहीं कर सकता तो वह
चीट चट मैंने बनाई हुई है और व चीट चट मैं
आपके सामने रिप्रेजेंट करूंगा तो अगर आपको
शायद मुझे लगता है कि आपको समझ में आ
जाएगा अगर समझ में नहीं आएगा तो आप मुझसे
पूछ सकते हैं और इस चीट सट को हम अपकमिंग
जैसे कि अभी नेक्स्ट जो सेशन रहेंगे
सिस्टम हैकिंग उसमें हम यूज कर लेंगे
क्योंकि हमरे लब्स की कमी नहीं होगी उस उस
टाइम पर
ओके सो दे 32 स्टूडेंट्स
ओनली तो एक काम करते हैं हम अपने सेशन को
स्टार्ट करते हैं क्योंकि चीटशीट भी लंबी
है और और कोशिश करते हैं कि सेशन को वन
एंड हाफ मैक्स में हम खत्म कर देते हैं
वेरी गुड इवनिंग रोहन तो सेशन को खत्म
करने के बावजूद हम क्या करेंगे नेक्स्ट जो
सेशन स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं आप लोग आप
सबका फेवरेट सेशन है जो आप चाहते थे
लिनक्स प्रिविलेज लिनक्स हैकिंग विंडोज
हैकिंग या सिस्टम हैकिंग जिसको हम बोल
सकते हैं वह स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं तो
नेक्स्ट सेशन से या नेक्स्ट क्लास से हम
अपनी जो रियल जर्नी है जो जितनी भी नॉलेज
अभी तक यूज की है उसके बेस पर हम उसको
फर्द एहस करने वाले हैं और भी ज्यादा
नॉलेज गेन करने वाले हैं और हैकिंग की
एक्चुअल वलन बिलिटी के थ्रू हम उसको
एक्सप्लोइट करेंगे एक्सेस गेन करेंगे
एक्सेस गेन करने के बावजूद फिर हम क्या
करेंगे उसपे प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन करेंगे
और फर्द फर पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन के फेज
परफॉर्म करेंगे तो कुछ लैब्स हैं कुछ 2030
लैब्स होंगी जिनको हम परफॉर्म करने वाले
हैं तो उसके बाद आप का एक लेवल हो जाएगा
कि आप एक लेवल पर जाकर इंटरमीडिएट लेवल पर
उनको क्या कर सकते हो पेन टेस्टिंग कर
सकते हो देन उसके बाद नेक्स्ट सेक्शन
देखेंगे नेक्स्ट सेक्शन हमारा क्या रहेगा
बट फरदर प्लान यही है और यह जो सिस्टम
हैकिंग का जो ड्यूरेशन है वह काफी लॉन्ग
रहने वाला है कि ऐसा नहीं कि सर 10 15
नहीं मे बी 30 40 वीडियोस होंगी उनकी
टोटली तो 30 40 वीडियोस के अंदर जाके आपका
क्या है लाइव सेशन के अंदर जाकर आपका जो
सिस्टम हैकिंग का जो पार्ट है वो कवर होगा
तो बने रहिए और इनको तो बिल्कुल ही मिस मत
करना और मैं चाहता हूं कि मैक्सिमम जितने
स्टूडेंट लाइव में आ सकते हैं उतने आइए
क्योंकि उसमें हम मैं क्या करूंगा कि अभी
आप लोगों से पूछूंगा मैं ओके आप लोगों से
मैं यह पूछूंगा कि ओके अभी मुझे क्या करना
चाहिए अभी मैं कमांड परफॉर्म कर रहा हूं
और मुझे क्या टेक्निक अपनानी चाहिए या
मुझे अभी कौन सी कमांड क्या यहां पर
परफॉर्म करना चाहिए सारी चीजें मैं आपसे
पूछूंगा चैट के थ्रू तो चैट के थ्रू हम
ज्यादा से ज्यादा इंटरेक्शन करेंगे थोड़ी
सी लैब जो सीटीएफ हम परफॉर्म करेंगे वो
थोड़ा सा स्लो जाएगा बट उसमें क्या है कि
जितने भी लाइव स्टूडेंट लाइव होंगे
स्टूडेंट्स क्लास के अंदर सभी के सभी
इंटरेक्ट कर पाएंगे अपने आईडिया दे पाएंगे
और साथ के साथ चाहे तो साथ के साथ कर भी
सकते हैं वे
ओके नहीं वीडियो नहीं अटक रही
वो शायद वीडियो सही परफॉर्म कर रही है
तो अभी हम सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं तो
प्लीज आई रिक्वेस्ट बारबार हमेशा आप लोगों
से रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं कि सेशन मत मिस
कीजिए और आगे वाले सेशन बिल्कुल भी मिस मत
करना क्योंकि वहां पर हम कमांड इजेक्शन
आरसी एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन से हम अपनी सेल
में कन्वर्ट करना वह सारी चीजें सीखने
वाले
हैं नहीं प्लीज बताइए एक बार सभी लोग मेरी
ऑडियो रुक कर आ रही है क्या एनी प्रॉब्लम
कोई भी
बताइए प्लीज बताइए अभी
बताइए प्लीज आप लोग भी एक बार इन आउट होके
देखिए ओके ओके
ओके चलो सेशन को स्टार्ट करें अभी
इट्स ओके तो मेरी यह चीटशीट है सबसे पहले
हम परफॉर्म करने वाले हैं वेब सर्वर
एन्यूमरेशन ओके वेब सर्वर एमेशन हम
परफॉर्म करने वाले हैं मैं थोड़ा सा जूम
कर दूं आपको यह दिखाई दे रहा होगा शायद
सबको दिखाई दे रहा
है अब इस परे जूम नहीं कर पाएंगे
हम सबको दिखाई दे रहा
है थोड़ा आप खुद से अपने अगर मोबाइल
डिवाइस पर हो तो आप खुद से जूम कर सकते हो
तो देखिए सबसे पहले मेरे पास एक टारगेट था
जिसका नाम था विक्टिम वन उस परे मैंने पिन
किया पिन करने के बावजूद वहां पर मुझे
रिस्पांस मिलता है उस रिस्पांस से मुझे
पता चल गया कि जो मेरा टारगेट है जो
टारगेट मशीन है मेरी वो क्या है एक्टिव है
उसके बाद मैं एमएसएफ कंसोल का यूज करता
हूं और एमएसएफ कंसोल को स्टार्ट करते हैं
देन एमएसएफ कंसोल में एक मॉड्यूल यूज करते
हैं हम ऑक्सल स्कैनर एचटीटीपी एटीटीपी
वर्जन आप सबको पता है मॉड्यूल को सर्च
कैसे करते हैं तो मैं डायरेक्टली मॉड्यूल
का नाम आपके सामने शो करता हूं तो एटीटीपी
वर्जन मॉड्यूल को हम यूज करते हैं तो इस
मॉड्यूल का बेसिक फंक्शन क्या है मैं
इसमें बता देता हूं कि दिस मॉड्यूल इज यूज
फॉर एचटीटीपी रिकंस रिकॉन हेल्पिंग यू
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
ओके दिस मॉड्यूल सेंड्स एचटीटीपी
रिक्वेस्ट टू द टारगेट एंड एनालाइज द सर्व
रिस्पांस टू एक्सकटुन फॉर्मेशन क्या करता
है कि जो एचटीटीपी वर्जन मॉड्यूल है यह
एटीटीपी रिकंस मॉड्यूल है यह रिकन करता है
एडीटीपी का यह आपके सर्वर के पास
रिक्वेस्ट भेजता है और उसका जो रिस्पांस
आता है उस रिस्पांस को एनालाइज करता है और
उसके एनालिसिस के बेस पर आपको जो
इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड करता है व क्या करता
है एचटीटीपी सर्वर वर्जन जैसे कि अचे है
एजक्स है माइक्रोसॉफ्ट है उसका कौन सा
वर्जन एटीटीपी प्रोटोकॉल्स कौन सा
प्रोटोकॉल वर्जन यूज हो रहा एटीपी 1.1 या
एटीटीपी 2.0 स्टेटस कोड 200 ओके है या
4040 फाउंड है या 4034 डन है हेडल्स की
डिटेल्स अगर वहां पर उसको मिलती है तो
कंटेंट टाइप जैसे कि डाटा या कनेक्शंस
या जो टारगेट है उसकी फिंगर प्रिंटिंग
करता है प्रोवाइड हिंट्स अबाउट द सर्वर्स
अंडरलाइन ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स एंड सॉफ्टवेयर
स्टैक बेस्ड ऑन द एक्सट्रैक्टेड
इंफॉर्मेशन बेसिकली जैसे कि रिस्पांस आता
है स्कैनिंग टारगेट सोन सो सर्वर अचे
2.4.4 62 एटीटीपी 1.12 ओके कंटेंट टाइप
टेक्स्ट और एचटीएमएल उसके बाद कनेक्शन की
अपलाई अब एडिशनल नोट्स में एक इंपोर्टेंट
इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड की गई यहां पर आपको
ध्यान देना चाहिए द सर्वर वर्जन कैन सम
टाइम्स बी ऑफस केटेड फॉर सिक्योरिटी रीजन
अब जो सर्वर का वर्जन है उसको कई बार
सिक्योरिटी रीजन से हाइड भी किया जा सकता
है छुपाया भी जा सकता है इन सच केसेस ए
रिकन टेक्निक माइट बी रिक्वायर्ड पेयर दिस
मॉडल विद अदर एचटीटीपी स्कैनर अभी इस मॉडल
को हम क्या कर सकते हैं जो दूसरे एचटीटीपी
स्कैनर्स है जो मॉड्यूल अवेलेबल है उनके
साथ पेयर करके हम इस इंफॉर्मेशन को फाइंड
आउट कर सकते हैं जैसे कि एचटीटीपी हेडर है
या एचटीटीपी एनम है फॉर ए मोर
कंप्रिहेंसिव एनालिसिस दिस मॉड्यूल इज
वेरी वेरी पावरफुल मॉड्यूल फॉर गैदरिंग
बेसिक बट क्रिटिकल इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट ए वेब
सर्वर जैसे के लिए मैंने क्या किया यूज
ऑरी स्कैनर एचटीटीपी एचटीटीपी वर्जन उसके
बाद जब वहां पर मैंने आरओ सेट किया यहां
पर डोमेन नेम सेट किया देन उसके बाद मैंने
डायरेक्टली इसको रन कर दिया रन करने पर
मुझे जो इंफॉर्मेशन मिली वह मिली अचे 2 प
4.18 122 मतलब नक् मशीन है अभी मुझसे मुझे
मुझसे एक चीज क्लियर होगई यहां पर मुझे एक
चीज बिल्कुल क्लियर है कि जो डोमेन है
मतलब ये जो वेब सर्वर है किसके ऊपर होस्ट
किया गया है नटू के ऊपर पोस्ट किया गया है
और वेब सर्वर जो न्यूमरेशन करते हो उस केस
में एक चीज ध्यान में रखिए ओके कि अगर
आपका वेब
सर्वर सही से कंफिल नहीं है तो आपको बहुत
सारी क्रिटिकल इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड कर
सकता है ओके ड्यू टू मिस कॉन्फिन अगर आपका
वेब सर्वर वेल
कॉन्फिडो देखने को नहीं मिलेगी ये पॉइंट
बिल्कुल ध्यान में रखिए आप ओके तो पहला जो
मैंने मॉड्यूल यूज किया वो कौन सा है
एडीपी वर्जन उससे मुझे फाइंड आउट किया कि
कौन सा एचटीटीपी कौन सा वेब सर्वर यूज
किया जा रहा है अपाचे वेब सर्वर न टू मशीन
के ऊपर एवरीथिंग क्लियर यहां तक सबको
क्लियर है यह चीज समझ में आई
सबको यह चीज सबको क्लियर आ रही है समझ में
आई प्लीज बताओ
नहीं यार शायद
नहीं नहीं माय नेटवर्क इ ओके फाइन और
स्ट्रीमिंग इ आल्सो
फाइन
ओके नेक्स्ट जो मॉड्यूल हमने यूज किया लरी
स्कैनर टीप robots.txt वाला robots.txt
अब यह मॉड्यूल क्या करता है दिस मॉड्यूल
रिट्रीव्स एंड एनालाइज द robots.txt फाइल
फ्रॉम ए टारगेट वेब सर्वर दिस फाइल इज
यूज्ड बाय द वेबसाइट्स टू गिव इंस्ट्रक्शन
टू वेब क्रॉलर अब बेसिकली सबको पता है जब
मैंने स्टार्टिंग में ही आपको बताया था जब
हम
google.it एकटी फाइल क्या होती है
robot.txt फाइल क्या है वेब क्रॉलर यूज़
करते हैं यह किस को वेबसाइट को क्रॉल करने
के लिए ओके इंडेक्सिंग करने के लिए और
उसके अंदर डिफाइंड होता है उस लिस्ट के
अंदर कि आपको क्या क्रॉल करना है और क्या
नहीं कन क्रॉल करना अब इससे कई बार आपको
क्या होता है कुछ सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन
होती है हिडन डायरेक्टरीज की या फाइल्स की
जो आपको मिल जाती है इस फाइल से और जरूरी
नहीं कि ये फाइल्स हर एक वेबसाइट के ऊपर
मिल जाए जरूरी भी नहीं है कई इसको हाइड भी
कर देते हैं ड्यू टू सिक्योरिटी रीजन अभी
मैंने इसको यूज किया यूज ऑक्सल स्कैनर
एचटीटीपी रोबोट 10.txt इसके लिए हमने आरओ
सेट किया फिर रन किया तो इसने जो
इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड कि आप डायरेक्टली भी
फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो ये इंफॉर्मेशन
यूजर एजेंट टेस्ट डायरेक्टरी मतलब अलाव
क्या आपको वेब मेल लेकिन डिस अलाव क्या है
अंडरस्कोर डाटा अंडरस्कोर सिक्योर मतलब दो
हमें क्या मिली डायरेक्टरीज मिली जो डिस
अलाव है मतलब कुछ ना कुछ इसके अंदर
सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन हो सकती
है उसके बाद मैं यूज करता हूं एक और ऑक्सल
स्कैनर हेडर मॉड्यूल यह क्या करता है इट
कलेक्ट एंड एनालाइज एचटीटीपी रिस्पांस
हेडर फ्रॉम ए टारगेट वेब सर्वर यह क्या
करता है कि जो एचटीटीपी का जो रिस्पांस
मिलता है हमें टारगेट वेब सर्वर से उसको
क्या करता है एनालाइज करता है और उससे
इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट करता है यह भी इट
प्रोवाइड्स क्रिटिकल मेटा डाटा अबाउट द
सर्वर एंड इट्स कन्फेशन जैसे सॉफ्टवेयर
डिटेल हो गई सिक्योरिटी मैकेनिज्म हो गया
या कम्युनिकेशन प्रोटोकॉल किस टाइप की
जैसे सर्वर फॉर्मेशन में जैसे अचे एजक्स
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट आईएस प्रोटोकॉल्स इंफॉर्मेशन
सिक्योरिटी हेडर्स जैसे
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
की यह हेडर्स लगा है या नहीं लगा है एक्स
कंटेंट टाइप ऑप्शंस जो आपको प्रोटेक्ट
अगेंस्ट एमआईएम बेस्ड अटैक्स स्ट्रिक्ट
ट्रांसपेरेंसी सिक्योर्ड एचएसटीएस ये आगे
इस इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल है हेडर में या
नहीं है जो आपको एचटीटीपीएस इफोर्स करने
के लिए
मतलब फोर्स करता है एंड कुकीज की की
कैप्चर सेट कुकीज हेडर रिवीलिंग सेशन मतलब
कंपलीटली आपका जो जब एचटीटीपी हेडर है जो
इंफॉर्मेशन पूरी हेडर इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड
करता है व
इनकोडिंग कंप्रीहेंशन रीडायरेक्शन
इंफॉर्मेशन यह सारी अब यहां पर कुछ
इंपोर्टेंट पॉइंट मैं आपको बता रहा हूं कि
हम इस मॉड्यूल को क्यों यूज करते हैं देखो
कॉमन मिसिंग हेडर्स फाइंड आउट करने के लिए
अगर फॉर एग्जांपल स्ट्रिक्ट ट्रांसपेरेंसी
ट्रांसपोर्ट ट्रांसपोर्ट सिक्योरिटी अगर
ये मिस है हेड मतलब क्या है कि अटैकर्स
क्या कर सकते हैं अ एचटीटीपीएस कनेक्शन को
डाउनग्रेड कर सकते किसके अंदर एचटीटीपी के
अंदर लैक ऑफ एक्स फ्रेम ऑप्शंस मतलब क्क
जैकिंग अटैक्स भी परफॉर्म हो सकता है अगर
वल्नरेबल है तो सिक्योरिटी बेस्ट
प्रैक्टिसेस क्या है यहां पर इंश्योर ऑल
सेंसिटिव हेडर्स आर इंप्लीमेंटेड टू
रिड्यूस एक्सपोजर टू कॉमन वेब वनबिल और इस
मॉड्यूल को हम क्या कर सकते हैं एचटीटीपी
वर्जन या एचटीटीपी ब्रूट द ब्रूट फोर्स
मॉड्यूल उसके साथ भी क्या कर सकते हो आप
पेयर करके फर्द इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग कर
सकते हो एन्यूमरेशन कर सकते
हो अभी मैंने क्या किया एटीपी हेडर को यूज
किया ओनली पर्टिकुलर सिक्योर किसके लिए
उसके अंदर सेट आ रस्ट टारगेट आईपी सेट
किया टारगेट यू
आरआर जगह से जिस पर्टिकुलर
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री टारगेट यू आरआईए अंदर
तो यहां पर हमने सिक्योर क्योंकि हमने दो
डायरेक्टरी देखी थी हिडन जो डिस अलाव थी
डाटा और सिक्योर तो यहां पर हम जो सेट
किया टारगेट यू आरआर के लिए जब हमने रन
किया तो यहां पर इंफॉर्मेशन हमें क्या
मिली कंटेंट टाइप टेक्स्ट एचटीएमएल और
कैरेक्टर सेट आईएसओ इससे हमें पता चल गया
कि कौन से टाइप की लैंग्वेज यूज की जा रही
है मतलब एचटीएमएल कैरेक्टर सेट फिर देखिए
आप सर्वर इंफॉर्मेशन मिल गई इसको और
ऑथेंटिकेशन बेसिक ऑथेंटिकेशन किया जा रहा
है इसके ऊपर जो सिक्योर है यहां पर क्या
ऑथेंटिकेशन फॉर्म है लॉगिन फॉर्म है ओके
एवरीवन गट क्लियर टिल
नाउ तीन मॉड्यूल में आपको बता चुका
एटीटीपी वर्जन रोबोट्स टी एक्सटी और
एचटीटीपी
हेडर अखिलेश कौन सा रिपीट करना है बताइए
हां ये पप पर ये चीटशीट दोनों आज के जो
सेशन की चीटशीट है यह भी मिल जाएगी ये
चीटशीट को मैं फॉरवर्ड कर दूंगा और सर को
अपलोड करने के लिए बोल दूंगा डेफिनेटली
आपको कंप्लीट चीट शट मिल जाएगी विद
फोटोग्राफ्स बताइए बताइए बताइए
बताइए
कि अभी तक समझ में आ गया सबको और जो रिपीट
करने के लिए बोल रहे थे प्रने क्या रिपीट
करना था
बताइए टॉपिक यह है कि आप वेब सर्वर
एन्यूमरेशन कर रहे हैं मतलब आपका जो
टारगेट है टारगेट के ऊपर वेब सर्वर रनिंग
है जब आपने सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन किया ए
मैप के थ्रू वहां पर पोर्ट एटी पर आपने
क्या मिला एडीटीपी अपाचे वेब सर्वर मिला
तो उस वेब सर्वर की अभी मैं क्या कर रहा
हूं एनिमेशन परफॉर्म कर रहा हूं और
एनिमेशन परफॉर्म करने के लिए अभी मैं यूज
कर रहा हूं एमएसएफ कंसोल को जो आपका
ऑटोमेशन वाला तरीका ना उसको यूज कर रहे
हैं उसके बाद जो मैनुअल में जो टेक्निक्स
होगी थोड़ी बहुत वो मैं आपको बता दूंगा
स्क्रीन के सामने राइट डाउन कर दूंगा
ओके तो अभी जो नेक्स्ट मॉड्यूल मैं आपको
बताने के लिए जा रहा हूं यह आपका एचटीटी
ऑक्ल स्कैनर एचटीटीपी ब्रूट डायरेक्टरीज
ओके दिस मॉड्यूल इज यूज फॉर ब्रूट फोर्स ए
वेब सर्वर टू डिस्कवर हिडन डायरेक्टरीज
एंड फाइल्स बेसिकली जो ब्रूट डीआर मॉड्यूल
है इस मॉड्यूल का यूज करते
हम ब्रूट फोर्सिंग के लिए डायरेक्टरी
ब्रूट फोर्सिंग मतलब जो हिडन डायरेक्टरीज
है या जो फाइल्स है उस इंफॉर्मेशन को
डिस्कवर करने के लिए हम क्या करते हैं
फाइंड आउट करने के लिए हम इस मॉड्यूल का
यूज करते हैं और इस मॉड्यूल में हमें
चाहिए होती है वर्ड लिस्ट बाय डिफॉल्ट
इसके पास भी एक वर्ड लिस्ट होती है लेकिन
सबसे अच्छा तरीका यही रहता है कि अगर आपके
पास अपनी इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग के थ्रू एक
वर्ड लिस्ट है प्रिपेयर्ड वर्ड लिस्ट है
तो वो आपको काफी इफेक्टिव रहेगी ओके तो
बाय यूटिलाइजिंग ए वर्ड लिस्ट इट सेंड्स
एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट टू द टारगेट एंड
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
डायरेक्टरी या बैकअप डायरेक्टरी टेस्ट
पीएचपी फाइल मिली है उसका रिस्पांस क्या
है 200 ओके है मतलब डायरेक्टरी और फाइल
एजिस्ट करती है या 403 फॉर
बिडनल है बट एजिस्ट करती है या 301 है 302
है या 404 मतलब पाथ डज नॉट
एजिस्ट इससे आपको आईडिया लग जाता है उसकी
साइट मैप का और एडिशनल इंफॉर्मेशन में आप
खुद से पढ़ लेना जब आपको नोट्स मिल जाएंगे
इसको दूसरे जो मॉड्यूल उनके साथ क्या कर
सकते हो आप कंबाइन भी कर सकते हो लेकिन एक
इंपोर्टेंट चीज यहां पर हाईलाइट कर देता
हूं एक तो ल्ट वर्ड लिस्ट वाली द मॉड्यूल
इंक्लूड्स ए बिल्ड इन वर्डलिस्ट बट कस्टम
वर्डलिस्ट कैन इंप्रूव एक्यूरेसी एंड
एफिशिएंसी अगर आपके पास खुद के वर्ड लिस्ट
है तो एक्यूरेसी और एफिशिएंसी दोनों ही
बढ़ जाएगी आपकी दूसरा आपको क्या करना है
सर्वर को ओवरलोड होने से अवॉइड करना है और
अवॉइड करने के लिए आपको जो न थ्रेड्स होते
हैं क्योंकि एक ऑप्शंस होता है मॉड्यूल के
अंदर थ्रेड्स वो आपको कंट्रोल करने हैं
ठीक है वो कंट्रोल कैसे कर सकते हो सेट
थ्रेड्स इक्वल टू 5 या 10 इससे ज्यादा ना
रखे सो दैट की जो आपका जो सर्वर है उस पे
ओवरलोड ना है वरना वो भी क्या है रिस्पांस
देना बंद कर देगा बार-बार आपको क्या है
वैलिड चीज भी फेल हो जाएगी और जैसे कि
मैंने इसको यूज किया यूज ऑक्सल स्कैनर
एचटीटीपी ब्रूट डायरेक्टरीज सेट आर होस्ट
और डायरेक्टली रन किया तो इस तरीके से
आपको इंफॉर्मेशन देखो फाइंड विक्टिम वन
डॉक 200 ओके प्रोक 200 क्योंकि इसके अंदर
दो ही फाइल मिली तो इसलिए इसने इसको 200
ओके कर दिया अगर फर्द कोई भी डायरेक्टरी
या फाइल होती अगर उनका जो भी रिस्पांस
होता उसको ये रिस्पॉन्ड कर देता बिल्कुल
ये आपके डेमो के लिए है एक
स्क्रीनशॉट नेक्स्ट जो आपका मॉड्यूल है वह
है आपका ऑक्सल स्कैनर एचटीटीपी डीडीआईआर
लिस्टिंग डायरेक्टरी लिस्टिंग दिस मॉड्यूल
स्कैंस फॉर डायरेक्टरी लिस्टिंग वल्नरेबल
कीज ऑन ए टारगेट वेब सर्वर डायरेक्टरी
लिस्टिंग ओकर्स व्हेन ए वेब सर्वर अलाउ
यूजर टू व्यू द कंटेंट ऑफ ए डायरेक्टरी
दैट लैक्स एंड इंडेक्स फाइल दिस कैन
एक्सपोज सेंसिटिव फाइल्स स्क्रिप्ट्स और
कन्फेशन दैट शुड रिमन प्राइवेट बेसिकली
क्या है कि जो डायरेक्टरी लिस्टिंग
लेबिलिटी होती है मतलब क्या कि जो आपका
सर्वर होता है उसके अंदर
एक फाइल होती है कहां पर कहां पर कहां पर
यह रहा यह रहा
हा मतलब आप क्या कर सकते हो इसके थ्रू
डायरेक्टरी या फाइल की इंफॉर्मेशन को क्या
फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो जहां पर क्या है कुछ
आपको सेंसिटिव कॉन्फिन फाइल्स मिल जाए या
आपको कुछ बैकअप फाइल मिल जाए या कुछ
सेंसिटिव डाटा या आपको की मिल जाए या कुछ
इंपॉर्टेंट कुकीज मिल जाए या एपीआई की मिल
जाए या आपके डेटाबेस की फाइल मिल जाए या
एरर की फाइल मिल जाए या आपकी बात करें कि
एनवायरमेंट की फाइल मिल जाए यह सारी सारी
क्या है आप क्या कर सकते हो यहां पर फाइंड
आउट कर सकते हो लिस्ट लिस्ट के थ्रू ओके
तो यह देखिए यहां पर भी यूज ऑक्सल स्कैनर
डायरेक्ट लिस्टिंग आर होस्ट पाथ डाटा अभी
मैं डटा पे फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश कर
रहा हूं रन किया चाहो तो मैं रूट पे भी
फाइंड आउट कर सकता हूं रूट आपको पता है
मतलब जो रूट होता है वेब सर्वर
का ओके आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट तो इस तरीके से
अभी देखिए एक और एक और रन किया मैंने ये
रहा यूज ऑक्सल स्कैनर एचटीटीपी फाइल्स
डायरेक्टरी ये डायरेक्टरी लिस्टिंग है और
एक नेक्स्ट मॉड्यूल एक और होता है ऑक्सल
स्कैनर एचटीटीपी फाइल्स डीआई आर अभी दोनों
लग इसका अलग काम है मैंने इससे पहले आपको
दिखाया था एक डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग
ये क्या है यह भी सेम काम करता है
डायरेक्टरी प्लस में फाइल ब्रूट फोर्सिंग
इसमें भी क्या है डिफॉल्ट वर्ड लिस्ट होती
है आप चाहो तो खुद की वर्ड लिस्ट भी कस्टम
वर्ड लिस्ट डिफाइन कर सकते हो अब इसने
क्या किया अपनी वर्डलिस्ट को सेलेक्ट किया
सेट आर होस्ट सेट वर्ब होस फाल्स रन किया
तो इसने सभी इसके वर्डलिस्ट के अंदर जो भी
फाइल मेंशन थी सबको इसने चेक किया डॉट नल
डॉट बैकअप देखो फाइल डॉट बैक अप 200 ओके
नाउ उसके बाद डॉट बैकड स द कोड ड स 200
ओके कोड सीएफजी 200 ओके इक्सड
html2pdf सकते हो ओके एवरीवन गट क्लियर
टिल
नाउ साइबर बय वर्डलिस्ट डिपेंड करता है कि
आप खुद से भी बना सकते हो टूल्स होते हैं
खुद से वर्डलिस्ट क्रिएट करने के लिए करं
जैसे टूल होते हैं और अदर वाइज क्या कर
सकते हो कि आप जो डिफॉल्ट वर्ड लिस्ट होती
है आप गिट हब से भी डाउनलोड करके यूज कर
सकते हो तीसरी एफ कंसोल के पास एक बाय
डिफॉल्ट वर्ड लिस्ट डाउनलोड होती है चौथा
रोक
रो रो क्यूटी एक्सटी जो वर्ड लिस्ट होती
है वह भी आप क्या कर सकते हो यूज कर सकते
हो तो दे लॉट ऑफ वर्ड लिस्ट आर अवेलेबल बट
रियल सिनेरियो में बेस्ट पार्ट इज कस्टम
वर्डलिस्ट जो आपके खुद के द्वारा डिजाइन
की जाएगी आपकी इंफॉर्मेशन के आधार पर ओके
जब हम सीटीएफ या जो लैब्स करेंगे ना उससे
आपको पता चल जाएगा कि कस्टम वड लिस्ट भी
आपके लिए कैसे हेल्पफुल होती है क्योंकि
उसमें सारी चीजें होंगी आपकी कि आप ओसेंट
भी थोड़ा बहुत यूज कर रहे होगे कॉमन सेंस
यूज कर रहे होगे टूल्स यूज करोगे
वर्डलिस्ट यूज करोगे गेन एक्सेस करोगे फिर
फर्द एक्सेस गेन करोगे क्लियर योर ट्रैक्स
तो सारी चीजें रहेंगी आपकी तो यहां तक
जितने भी मॉड्यूस मैंने आपको बताए क्लियर
है
मोहम्मद अगर आपके पास जब आपके पास एक
टारगेट होता ना जब आपने टारगेट चूज कर
लिया तो उस परे जब यह सारी चीज आप ट्राई
करते हो टारगेट के ऊपर अभी आप डिपेंड करता
है कि उसके ऊपर कितनी सिक्योरिटी लगी है
फिर वह चीजें सिनेरियो अलग आते हैं वहां
पर एंटीवायरस बायपास होते हैं जैसे इजन
टेक्निक्स होती है इजन टूल्स होते हैं तो
वो तरीके फिर एडवांस में जा है बट हां न
लेन आपने क्या किया अभी फॉर एग्जांपल अभी
डोमेन है डोमेन एक आईपी प काम करता है
आपको सबसे पहले पब्लिक फेसिंग सर्वर मिलता
है पब्लिक फेसिंग सर्वर के बाद फिर आप
उसमें एक्सेस गेन कर लेते हो एक्सेस गेन
करने के बाद आप क्या करते हो फिर फर्द से
नमरे परफॉर्म करते हो पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन
की एक फेज होता है पूरा लोकल एन्यूमरेशन
फिर उसमें प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन अगर प
चाहिए तो उसके बाद उसमें और भी बहुत सारी
चीज होती है सिक्स टू सेवन फेज की वो होती
है व होती है पीवीटी ये सारी चीजें होती
है तो व फर्द करते हो लेकिन स्टार्टिंग
फेज आपका क्या रहता है न्यूमरेशन के बाद
एक्सप्लोइट करना होता है वटी को फाइंड आउट
करना है एक बार टी आपको मिल जाती है फिर
आप क्या करते हो एक्सेस गेन करते हो
एक्सेस गेन करने के बाद आपको मेंटेन भी
करना पड़ता है एक्सेस एक्सेस मेंटेन करने
के बाद आप पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन प शिफ्ट
करते हो तो ये सारी चीजें मैं आपको अभी जो
नेक्स्ट इंट्रोडक्शन सेशन रहेगा सिस्टम
हैकिंग का उसमें स्टार्टिंग के दो लेक्चर
एटलीस्ट थ्योरी पार्ट है क्योंकि उसमें
अगर वो आपने मिस किए थ्योरी पार्ट तो शायद
आप बहुत कुछ मिस कर जाओगे क्योंकि उसमें
क्या है कि एक स्ट्रेटजी है एक टेक्निक्स
है एक मेथड है जो आप यूज करोगे जो आप यूज
करते हो आपको करनी चाहिए ड्यूरिंग
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग अगर आपको लगता है कि
थ्योरी के चक्कर में मैं इंटरेस्ट नहीं
हूं और मुझे उन दो लेक्चर को स्किप कर
दूंगा मैं दो क्लास को तो मैं आपको सच बोल
रहा हूं कि आप बहुत
पछताओगे मैं बोल रहा हूं क्योंकि उसमें
कुछ ऐसी चीजें होंगी हो सकता कि आप
आपने पहले पढ़ी होंगी लेकिन आपके लिए
रिवाइज करते हुए काफी यूजफुल हो आपको काफी
कुछ सीखने को मिले ओके तो डोंट मिस आउट हर
एक चीज हम स्टेप बाय स्टेप करेंगे तो ये
चीज आपको सबको समझ में आ गई होगी नेक्स्ट
एक होता है ऑरी स्कैनर एसटीटीपी पुट मेथड
अभी दिस मॉड्यूल इज यूज फॉर टेस्टिंग वेदर
ए टारगेट वेब सर्वर सपोर्ट द एचटीटीपी पुट
मेथड एचटीटीपी पुट क्या करता है इट इज यूज
टू अपलोड फाइल्स टू ए सर्वर सर्वर के र
फाइल अपलोड करने के लिए या डिलीट करने के
लिए भी हम इसका यूज करते हैं इफ ए सर्वर
इंप्रोपर्ली सपोर्ट्स पुट रिक्वेस्ट
विदाउट सफिशिएंट एक्सेस कंट्रोल्स और
वैलिडेशंस इट कुड अलाउ अटैकर्स टू अपलोड
मशियल फाइल्स पोटेंशियली लीडिंग टू रिमोट
कोड एग्जीक्यूशन डेटा ब्रीचेज एंड वेब सेल
डिप्लॉयड अगर एचटीटीपी पुट मेथड को सही
तरह से वैलिडेट नहीं किया गया या उसपे
एक्सेस कंट्रोल नहीं किए गए वो मिस
है तो वहां पर आप रिमोट कोड एग्जीक्यूशन
जैसी वनटी या डेटा ब्रिज या आप बैक डोर
प्लांट करने में सक्सेसफुल हो सकते हो य
सारी वनटी आपको यहां पर देखने को मिल
जाएगी अगर यह मिस कन्फ गर्ड है तो एचडीपी
पुट मेथड तो इस मॉडल के थ्रू हम क्या कर
सकते हैं यह चीज टेस्ट करके देख सकते हैं
कि क्या एचटीटीपी पुट मेथड अगर पहले
एक्सेस है एक्सेसिबल है क्या वह मिस कन्फर
है या नहीं है ओके देखो यह क्या करता है
टेस्टिंग फॉर एचटीटीपी पुट ट ओके अपलोड
फाइल डिटेक्शन स्टेटस कोड
रिस्पांस टेस्टिंग फॉर पोटेंशियल फाइल
अपलोड वलने बिटी य सारे काम करता है यह
मॉड्यूल जैसे अभी देखिए यूज ऑक्सल स्कैनर
एचटीटीपी पुट सेट आर होस्ट टारगेट आईपी
पाथ सेट कर दिया हमने डाटा पर जो डाटा एक
अन डिस अलाउ जो डायरेक्टरी थी सेट फाइल
नेम डटी एक्टी मैं एक फाइल क्रिएट करना
चाहता हूं उसके अंदर जो डाटा है वेलकम टू
इसम अटक डिफेंस की एक लैब चाहिए देन उसके
बाद मैंने रन किया रन करने के बाद देखो
फाइल अपलोडेड सक्सेसफुली सक्सेस हो गया
यहां पर मतलब यहां पर आरसी ही रिमोट कोड
एग्जीक्यूशन भी आप कर सकते हो और यहां के
अंदर क्या बैक डोर प्लांट कर सकते हो आप
क्या कर सकते हो बैक डोर प्लांट करके
रिवर्स सेल गेन कर सकते हो देखो यहां पर
मैं इसको डाउनलोड भी कर सकता हूं डब्ल्यू
गेट कमांड की हेल्प से देन उसके बाद फिर
से मैं क्या किया एचटीटीपी पुट मेथड इस
फाइल को मैंने डिलीट भी कर दिया और डिलीट
करने के बाद इसको मैं नीचे वेरीफाई करके
देख रहा हूं कि क्या मैं इसको फिर से
एक्सेस कर पा रहा हूं फिर से मैं इसको
एक्सेस नहीं कर पा रहा हूं मतलब इस टाइप
की अगर आपको चीजें देखने को मिलती है वेब
सर्वर के केस में दज आर द वेरी वेरी
सिवियर वलने बिलिटी आप इससे तो आप क्या है
उस पूरे सिस्टम की बैंड बजा सकते हो सच
में बजा सकते हो क्योंकि इससे आप बैक डोर
प्लांट करोगे बैक डोर प्लांट करके फिर
उसमें रूट एक्सेस ट्राई करोगे रूट एक्सेस
या विंडो के केस में एडमिनिस्ट्रेशन
एक्सेस ट्राई करोगे अगर वो आप सक्सेस हो ग
देन तो आप पता नहीं अगर वो मल्टीपल अगर सर
उससे कनेक्टेड होगा सिस्टम से तो फर्द आप
क्या कर सकते हो लैटरल मूवमेंट या पि
विटिंग कर कर के फर्द सिस्टम को भी डैमेज
करने की कोशिश कर सकते हो दिस इ वेरी
सीवियर ये सिनेरियो अगर आप सोचोगे तो बहुत
बड़ा सिनेरियो है ओके तो दीज आर द मॉड्यूस
जो मैंने आपको बताया एक और था इसमें ऑक्सल
स्कैनर एचटीटीपी लॉगइन मॉड्यूस यह क्या
करता है आपका जो लॉगिन फॉर्म होता है वेब
सर्वर के अंदर उसपे ब्रूट फोर्स ट्राई
करता है उसपे यूजर नेम और पासवर्ड क्या का
जो ब्रूट फोर्स है उसको ट्राई करता है
उसके कॉमिनेशन को ट्राई करता है किसके
थ्रू वर्डलिस्ट के थ्रू जो वर्डलिस्ट हम
इसको प्रोवाइड करते हैं अगर वहां पर क्या
है कि कॉमन यूजर नेम या पासवर्ड यूज किए
गए हैं और या यूजर नेम आपके पास है
पासवर्ड आप ब्रूट फोर्स करना चाहते हो तो
कॉमन पासवर्ड यूज़ किया गया है और वीक
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन है वहां पर कैप्चा यूज नहीं
किया गया है या टू फैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन यूज़
नहीं किया गया है लिमिट नहीं लगाई गई है
ये सारी चीजें रहेंगी तो आप क्या है कि
वेरी इजली आप क्या कर सकते हो यहां पर वो
क्रेडेंशियल गेट कर सकते हो फाइंड आउट कर
सकते हो सक्सेसफुली ऑथेंटिकेट कर सकते हो
अपने आप को वेब सर्वर के अंदर यह देखिए
ब्रूट फोर्स लॉगइन अटेम्प्ट्स करता है द
मॉड्यूल अटेम्प्ट्स मल्टीपल यूजर्स नेम
एंड पासवर्ड कॉमिनेशन ऑन द टारगेट वेब
सर्वर्स लॉगइन फॉर्म टू आइडेंटिफिकेशन
इट हैंडल्स सेशन कुकिंग टू मेंटेन स्टेट
ड्यूरिंग लॉगइन अटेम्प्ट्स ओके देन उसके
बाद यू कैन कॉन्फिन कस्टम एचटीटीपी हैडर
जिसके अंदर आप कस्टम एचटीटीपी हैडर भी सेट
कर सकते हो अभी क्या है कि इन मॉड्यूस में
आपको कॉमन सेंस लगानी पड़ेगी अगर आपको
लगता है कि मुझे डिटेक्ट नहीं हो रहा है
या इ वेड करना है तो मॉडल्स जब आप यूज
करने वा रहे हो आपको मॉड्यूस के नाम पता
है लेकिन आप उसको अपने हिसाब से यूज़ करना
चाहते हो तो आपके पास सारे पैरामीटर होने
चाहिए सारे सिनेरियो आपके पास होने चाहिए
और वो सारे सिनेरियो सोच के मॉड्यूस के
बारे में एक बार सर्च कर लो अगर इस
मॉड्यूस के बारे में जट जीपीटी भी करोगे
आपको अच्छे से बता देगा काफी डिटेल्स में
स्टेप बाय स्टेप उसके बाद उस सिनेरियो को
इसके अंदर इंप्लीमेंट करो ठीक है और इसको
इंप्लीमेंट करके आप एक बेस्ट तरीके से
क्या कर सकते हो इसको मॉड्यूस को यूज कर
सकते हो अपने लिए ओके नाउ रिस्पांस कोड
एनालिसिस करता है तो इस इस तरीके से देखो
ये यूज किया हमने एचटीटीपी लॉगिन और
ऑथेंटिकेशन यूर सिक्योर क्योंकि सिक्योर
डायरेक्टरी पे लॉगइन फॉर्म था सेट वर्बोस
फाल्स किया और यहां पर लॉगिन सक्सेसफुली
बॉब यूजर नेम है उसका 12 3321 पासवर्ड है
क्योंकि कॉमन यूज क्योंकि वल्नरेबल मशीनस
है तो शायद ये सबको समझ में आ गया होगा
सारे के सारे यहां तक मॉड्यूल जितने भी
मैंने आपको बताए एमफ कंसोल मॉड्यूल सबको
समझ में आया एवरीवन गोट क्लियर टिल नाउ
बताइए सभी जवाब दीजिए जितने भी स्टूडेंट
है देर 40 स्टूडेंट्स या 30 स्टूडेंट्स 40
स्टूडेंट्स तो सभी का जवाब
चाहिए प्लीज एवरीवन रिप्लाई करो हर एक
जितने भी स्टूडेंट सभी के सभी रिप्लाई करो
हां बैकडोर प्लांट का मतलब क्या होता है
कि बैकडोर एक मिशिस कोड आप प्लांट कर सकते
हो मतलब एक सिस्टम के अंदर पीछे का दरवाजा
आपने क्या किया एक वलन बिलिटी फाइंड आउट
की वलन बिलिटी के थ्रू आपने एक्सेस गेन
किया एक्सेस गेन करने के बाद आपने क्या
सेल लिया सेल क्या होता है उसका जो
टर्मिनल होता है जिसको आप बोलते जो काली
टर्मिनल उसी को हम सेल बोलते हैं वो आपने
एक्सेस लिया अभी जिसके थ्रू आपने एक्सेस
लिया था फॉर एग्जांपल आपने आपको पता है
उसके अंदर वलने बिलिटी है और आपने क्या
किया ओके वनटी आपको पता है एक्सेस गेन कर
सकते हो आपके पास टेक्निक्स है और आपने
सिंपली आज का काम खत्म किया आपने ो सोचा
कि मैं आज रेस्ट करता हूं कल देखता हूं और
कल फॉर एग्जांपल टी काम नहीं की या कल तक
वो पैच हो गई उनको पता चल गया फिर क्या
करोगे उस केस में क्या करते हो आप
एक एक्सेस मेंटेन करने के लिए क्या करते
हो आप बैक डोर प्लांट करते हो कि अगर वो
टी पैच भी होगी तो आपने खुद का एक बैक डोर
रख दिया कि उसके अंदर उस सिस्टम के अंदर
मैं फिर से जा सकता हूं फिर से उसके
एक्सेस कर सकता हूं फिर से उस पर अगर मैं
फदर हैकिंग कर सकता हूं वो बोलते हैं हम
बैक
डोर ओके तो अभी एक और है कि ऑक्ल स्कैनर
एचटीटीपी अचे यूजर डायरेक्टरी एन मॉड्यूल
यह भी क्या डिजाइन किया गया है ऑटोमेट द
प्रोसेस ऑफ नमरे इि यूजर डायरेक्टरीज ऑन
अचे वेब सर्वर यह स्पेशली जो अचे वेब
सर्वर है उसके लिए इसको डिजाइन किया गया
है अचे एक पॉपुलर वेब सर्वर सॉफ्टवेयर है
हैज ए फीचर नोन एज यूजर ड उसके अंदर एक
यूजर डायरेक्टरी फीचर्स है यह क्या करता
है व्हिच अलाउ यूजर टू होस्ट पर्सनल
डायरेक्टरीज अंडर एक कॉमन यूआरएल पाथ यह
क्या करता है कि जो यूजर्स है वह अपने
कॉमनस उसके अंदर क्या कर सकते हैं अपने
खुद की डायरेक्टरीज क्या कर सकते
हैं होस्ट कर सकते हैं जैसे कि फॉर
एग्जांपल http.com यूजर नेम फॉलो बाय खुद
की डायरेक्टरी तो दीज डायरेक्टरीज कैन सम
टाइम्स कंटेन सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन एंड द
मॉड्यूल कैन बी यूज्ड टू चेक इफ यूजर
डायरेक्टरीज एजिस्ट ऑन अ टारगेट सिस्टम और
यह मॉड्यूल क्या करता है यह चेक करता है
कि क्या ये यूजर नेम्स या जो डायरेक्टरीज
है अभी सिस्टम पे एजिस्ट करती है या नहीं
है बेसिकली अब इसको भी हम क्या करते एक
वर्ड लिस्ट प्रोवाइड करते हैं उस वर्ड
लिस्ट को यह चेक करता है इस डायरेक्टरी के
अंदर क्योंकि यह एक फीचर्स है और जब यह
चेक करता है अगर कोई यूजर नेम मिलता है और
उसके अगेंस्ट कोई डायरेक्टरी मिलती है तो
हमें चेक करनी है कि उसके अंदर कोई
सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन तो नहीं है कोई
पासवर्ड कोई चैट कोई कम्युनिकेशंस कुछ ऐसी
वैल्युएबल इंफॉर्मेशन जो हमारे काम में आ
सकती है तो ये वही चीज है तो इसको भी यूज
करके दिखाया हुआ है देखिए ये रहा तो यहां
पर देखो रोटी बैकअप दे लट ऑफ लिस्ट मेल
मैन न्यू नोबडी प्रोक्सी सिंग सिस तो दे
लॉट ऑफ
डायरेक्टरीज उसको क्या है फाइंड आउट मिली
अचे के अंदर यूजर डायरेक्टरी के अंदर तो
स्क्रीनशॉट काफी छोटा है इसमें आपको देखने
को मिलेगा नहीं लेकिन माय एसक्यूएल में
जितने भी स्क्रीनशॉट है फुल स्क्रीन
स्क्रीनशॉट है आपको समझ में आ जाएंगे तो
यह था
आपका वेब सर्वर एमेशन और यह जो मैंने आपको
क्या मेटा स्लट के थ्रू बताया है लेकिन
ड्यूरिंग क्लासेस जब हम वेब सर्वर को यूज
करेंगे इस पर परफॉर्म करेंगे अटैक परफॉर्म
करेंगे तो ड्यूरिंग क्लासेस भी हम क्या
करेंगे जो एन मैप के इंपोर्टेंट जो
स्क्रिप्ट होती हैं वो हम यूज करेंगे ओके
अगर आप बोलोगे तो उनका नाम मैं आपको बता
दूंगा अगर आप लोगों को जरूरी है अदर वाइज
आज इसी से काम चला लेंगे तो सही रहेगा
क्योंकि टॉपिक बड़े
हैं तो बीच में भी हम कर सकते हैं
उनको जैसे स्क्रिप्ट कौन सी होती है आपकी
उसके अंदर एन मैप के अंदर एचटीटीपी एनम
स्क्रिप्ट होती है एचटीटीपी हेडर
स्क्रिप्ट होती है एचटीटीपी मेथड
स्क्रिप्ट होती है और हां ये ही और एक
स्क्रिप्ट बैनर ये तीन चार स्क्रिप्ट
ज्यादा मोस्ट पॉपुलर स्क्रिप्ट है कौन-कौन
सी मैं फिर से रिपीट करता हूं एचटीटीपी
एनम जो एचटीटीपी एमेशन परफॉर्म करती है
एचटीटीपी हेडर्स जो एचटीटीटीपी हेडर्स
इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड करती है इस हेडर की
तरह ही जो अभी हमने यूज किया था मॉडल
एडीटीपी मेथड्स जो यह बताती है कौन-कौन से
मेथड इसके अंदर अलाउड है पुट गेट पोस्ट यह
सारे तो यह इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड करती
स्क्रिप्ट तो यह तीन चार स्क्रिप्ट जो
ज्यादातर यूज की जाती है इन द केस ऑफ एनम
आई रिपीट अगेन एचटीटीपी एनम एटीपी हेडर्स
और थर्ड वन कौन सा है एचटीटीपी मेथड्स तो
स्क्रिप्ट के नाम भी मैंने आपको बता दिए
जो मोस्ट कॉमन यूज किए जाने वाली
स्क्रिप्ट्स
है आज जो सेशन में बताए हैं देखो मैंने
आपको चिट चट बता दी है क्योंकि जो लैब्स
है जिस पर मैंने ट्राई आउट कर रखे हैं और
जिससे मैंने चीट चट बनाई है प्रीमियम
लैब्स है आपको भी एक्सेस नहीं है उसका
उसके लिए आपको बहुत ज्यादा पैसे पे करने
पड़ेंगे
तो मैं आपको बता देता हूं डोंट ट्राई इट
अभी चिट चिट से कामला चला लीजिए क्योंकि
देखो जो सारे स्क्रीनशॉट मैंने अटैच किया
है उसके बाद मॉड्यूल को मैंने एक्सप्लेन
किया है लेकिन जैसे-जैसे हम क्या करेंगे
जब टारगेट परफॉर्म करेंगे तो टारगेट में
जब हम ये एनिमेशन परफॉर्म करनी होगी तो
मैं आपको बोल दूंगा कि ओके आप वेब जो वेब
सर्वर की एन्यूमरेशन जो चिट चट है एक बार
इस पे आप परफॉर्म करके देख लीजिए आपको
क्या-क्या इंफॉर्मेशन देखने को मिलती है
क्योंकि जब ये हम सीटी आप परफॉर्म करेंगे
वहां पर हमारे पास टारगेट होगा कहीं ना
कहीं तो अचे भी मिलेगा मायकल भी मिलेगा और
कहीं पर हमें एमएस स्कल भी मिलेगा तो वहां
पर आप परफॉर्म कर सकते हो खुद से तो आज अब
मैं बोलूंगा कि आज मेरे पास आई एम सॉरी
फॉर दैट क्योंकि मैं मेटा स्पल टेबल थ को
भी यूज़ करता हूं वो जो मेरे पास
एक्सेसिबल है उसपे अचे भी है माय एसक्यूएल
है एमएस एसक्यूएल नहीं है प्रॉब्लम इज दैट
कि जब इनको परफॉर्म करोगे तो वह सबफ
वल्नरेबल है बट उसके अंदर कुछ भी प्लांट
नहीं किया हुआ तो यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन इनके
थ्रू जो इंफॉर्मेशन मिल रही है आपको वह
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन मेटा स्टेबल टू और थी में
नहीं मिल पाती इसलिए मैंने उनको यूज नहीं
किया क्योंकि एक तो अननेसेसरी तीन सेशन
बनाने पड़ते दूसरा क्या है इंफॉर्मेशन
ज्यादा आती नहीं क्योंकि उनके पास सच में
इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं है बिल्कुल मिनिमम
इंफॉर्मेशन है इसलिए क्या कि टोटली
वल्नरेबल मशीनस है इसलिए स्क्रीनशॉट के के
साथ मैंने आपको एक्सप्लेन किया है जब आप
खुद से पढ़ोगे एक बार और स्क्रीनशॉट को
कंपेयर करोगे तो आपको पता चल जाएगा कि किस
टाइप के इंफॉर्मेशन यह प्रोवाइड कर रहे हो
एक प्रैक्टिकल जैसा ही सिनेरियो रहेगा
आपके सामने यह चीट चट रहेगी हम हमारी
अवेलेबल रहेगी व ₹ वाले
में ओके तो सबको क्लियर है वेब स नॉमिनेशन
माय एसक्यूएल और एमएस एसक्यूएल पर
चले
बताइए जल्दी से चैट में रिप्लाई कीजिए
बताइए चलो एक काम करते हैं आप लोगों के
लिए अबकी बार मैं आपको करता हूं इसको
एक्सपोज कर देता हूं 0 के साथ-साथ में
इसको पब्लिकली आज ग्रुप में डलवा दूंगा
मैं अपने इस ग्रुप में ऐड करवाने के लिए
मैं रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं अगर पॉसिबल होगी
तो क्योंकि मेरा प्राइवेट अकाउंट है वन
ड्राइव पर तो आई विल ट्राई कि इसका कुछ
कन्वर्जन हो जाए तो यह पीडीएफ प्रोवाइड
करने की कोशिश करूंगा अदर वाइज मैं आज
सर्फ इसके लिए मैं आप लोगों की रिक्वेस्ट
पर मैं कोशिश करता हूं कि इसको मेरे लिंकन
पर जो लिंकन पेज है उस पर मिल जाएगी आपको
यह चीट शट
मेरे लिंक दिन पर अखिलेश लिंक दिन पता
होगा ना तो उस परे जाइए और आपको मिल
जाएगी ओके तो अभी मैं इसको एक बार जूम आउट
कर देता हूं ये मेरा यह शायद आपके यह सही
क्लियर रहेगा आपके लिए सही है ना यह
एवरीवन क्लियर अभ सही
है यह मेरा माय स्कल नरेशन
है ओके अभी हम बात करते हैं माय एसकल
नरेशन की की एग्जांपल अभी मैंने क्या किया
हुआ है कि जैसे हमने एनम परफॉर्म किया एनम
परफॉर्म करने के बावजूद मेरे जो वेब सर्वर
था जो टारगेट था मेरा 192.18
2443 जोय मेरा टारगेट था इस टारगेट के ऊपर
माय एसक्यूएल सर्विस रन कर रही थी जो
पोर्ट नंबर 3306 को यूज कर रही थी क्योंकि
मा एल का डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट तो 3306 आई थिंक
यस 3306 है ना
बताइए 3306 है ना माय एएल
सर्विस ओके तो अभी हमने सबसे पहले क्या
किया कि हमने सेट जी आ रोस्ट किया अगर
मैंने आपको बताया था
एमएसएफ कंसोल के दौरान कि हम वेरिएबल सेट
कर सकते हैं ओके तो ग्लोबल और लोकल
वेरिएबल अभी मैंने क्या किया ग्लोबल
वेरिएबल सेट किया आर होस्ट का क्योंकि जब
भी मैं मॉड्यूस को यूज करूंगा तो जो आरस
की वैल्यू है वो ग्लोबली सेट होगी
ऑटोमेटिक उसके अंदर ऐड हो जाएगी तो सेट जी
का यूज करेंगे आर होस्ट टारगेट आईपी
एड्रेस तो आर होस्ट की वैल्यू सेट हो गई
मेरी उसके बाद मैंने मॉड्यूल सर्च किया
ऑक्सल माय एसक्यूएल अब मेरे पास नाइन
मॉड्यूस इसमें शो कर रहा है लेकिन आप जो
हमारी मशीनस है उसमें ज्यादा शो करेगा तो
माय एसक्यूएल माय एसक्यूएल राइ टेबल
डायरेक्टरीज माय एसक्यूएल फाइल एन्यूमरेशन
माय एसक्यूएल हैश डंप माय एसकल स्कीमा डंप
माय एल ऑथेंटिकेशन बायपास है डंप माय एल
एन माय एएल लॉगिन ये सारे मॉड्यूस क्या
करेगा आपके सामने शो करेगा तो मैं सबसे
पहले कौन सा यूज करता हूं मॉड्यूल नंबर
नाइन माय एसकल वर्जन मैं वर्जन फाइंड आउट
करने की कोशिश करता हूं तो जैसे मैंने
क्या किया व यूज नाइन और श ऑप्शंस अब इसके
अंदर कौन-कौन से ऑप्शंस मैं सेट कर सकता
हूं मॉड्यूल ऑप्शंस सेशंस अभी सेशंस हम कब
सेट करते हैं अभी क्या है इसको मैं क्या
कर सकता हूं पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन के बाद
भी मैं क्या कर सकता हूं उसको या
एक्सप्लोइटेशन के बाद भी यूज कर सकता हूं
जब मेरे पास क्या होगा मीटर प्रेटर सेशन
होगा लेकिन अभी मेरे पास कोई भी पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन एक्सप्लोइटेशन हुआ ही नहीं
है मैंने गेन एक्सेस किया नहीं है तो इसकी
जरूरत नहीं है अभी मैं यूज करूं आर होस्ट
सेट आस्ट में क्या क्या टारगेट आईपी
एड्रेस आर पोर्ट 3306 डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट आपका
अगर आपका पोर्ट चेंज है आपके केस में जब
भी आप परफॉर्म करोगे एमेशन या इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग 3306 की ज और कोई पोर्ट है माय एल
सर्वर तो आपको पोर्ट चेंज करना पड़ेगा
नंबर ऑफ थ्रेड में वन यूज कर रहा हूं और
सिंपली मैंने क्या किया इसको एक्सप्लोइट
किया एक्सप्लोइट करने के बाद जो
इंफॉर्मेशन सामने आई वो थी माय एसक्यूएल
सर्विस इज रनिंग पोर्ट नंबर
3306 उसका जो वर्जन था
5.5.6 नट ओके यह क्या है क्लीनेक्स मशीन
है जिसका वर्जन क्या है 14 तो सक्सेसफुली
हमें पता चल गया एक तो कि मा एल की कौन सी
वर्जन हम यूज कर रहे हैं दूसरा न टू मशीन
का कौन सा वर्जन यूज कर रहे हैं तो दोनों
में हम केस में क्या कर सकते हैं वनटी
फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करते हैं वनटी
असेसमेंट कर सकते हैं दोनों केस एक तो वनट
के ऊपर दूसरा माय एसकल इस वर्जन के ऊपर कि
ये पर्टिकुलर वर्जन अवेलेबल है या नहीं है
देन उसके बाद मॉड्यूल नंबर यूज सेन यूज
करता हूं सेवन नंबर कौन सा है मेरा ये रहा
माय एसक्यूएल योगिन अभी क्या है कि अभी
माय एसक्यूएल के केस में आपको अगर ज्यादा
से ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए तो सबसे पहले
आपके पास यूजर नेम और पासवर्ड होना चाहिए
डेटाबेस का यूजरनेम पासवर्ड होना चाहिए
तभी आप ज्यादा से ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड
आउट कर सकते है अदर वाइज इतनी इंफॉर्मेशन
आप फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो इससे ज्यादा या
थोड़ी बहुत और इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट कर
सकते इससे ज्यादा नहीं फाइंड आउट कर सकते
हो तो उसके लिए आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा
ब्रूट फोर्स ट्राई करना पड़ेगा फिर से अब
हम क्या करते हैं ब्रूट फोर्स ट्राई करने
के लिए हम यूज करते हैं माय एसक्यूएल
लॉगइन मॉड्यूल ओके और इसके अंदर क्या दिया
लॉट ऑफ ऑप्शंस अनमिस लॉगिन ये अभी सभी
ऑप्शंस को खुद से पना अटेम्प्ट टू लॉग इन
यस वाला ऑलरेडी इसने फॉल्स कर दिया
एनोनिमस लॉगिन हम क्या कर सकते हैं अभी
फॉल्स कर दिया मतलब हम ट्राई नहीं कर रहे
ब्लैंक पासवर्ड ट्रू लेकिन अभी हम ब्लैंक
पासवर्ड ट्राई नहीं कर रहे तो मैं क्या कर
रहा हूं यहां पर पासवर्ड मेरे पास है नहीं
हां पास फाइल के अंदर मैं क्या पासवर्ड
वर्डलिस्ट पास करूंगा आस्ट मेरा सेट है
उसके बाद यूजर नेम्स अभी मैंने इसके अंदर
सेट कर दिया रूट क्योंकि बाय डिफॉल्ट आगे
अ ज्यादा पावरफुल होता एडमिन होता है या
रूट होता है तो हम क्या कर सकते हैं रूट
ट्राई कर रहे हैं अ पाचे के केस में तो
रूट ट्राई किया और मैं पासवर्ड इस पे क्या
है सेट यूजर नेम रूट सेट पास फाइल मैं
यक्स password.txt वर्डलिस्ट यूज़ कर रहा
हूं यूजर शेयर मेटा स्लट फ्रेमवर्क डटा
वर्डलिस्ट यक्स password.txt देन वर्ब वॉस
फॉल्स कर दिया अगर वर्ब वास ट्रू रहता तो
ये हर एक जो ट्राई थे उसको क्या करता शो
करता स्क्रीन के सामने और जब यह शो करता
तो क्या कि अननेसेसरी स्क्रीन भरती रहती
मेरी अभी क्या फालतू की चीजें कुछ भी
दिखाई नहीं देंगी स्क्रीन के ऊपर अभी अगर
ये फॉल्स रहेगा डायरेक्टली जो सक्सेस
रहेगा वही आपके सामने शो करेगा तो मैंने
जैसे रन किया तो सक्सेसफुली रूट और उसका
जो पासवर्ड क्या मिना टंकल टी डब्लू आई एन
के एल ये इसका पासवर्ड है तो सक्सेसफुली
हमने क्या कर लिया ब्रूट फोर्स के थ्रू
यूजर्स नेम और पासवर्ड गेट कर लिया जब
हमारे पास यूजर नेम और पासवर्ड मिल गया
हमें तो हम क्या करेंगे फिर से ट्राई करते
हैं ऑक्सल मॉड्यूल माय एसक्यूएल माय
एसक्यूएल में अभी हम यूज करेंगे कौन सा
सिक्स नंबर माय एसक्यूएल एनम तो सबसे पहले
मुझे बताए अभी तक जो कुछ जितने दो मॉड्यूल
बताए सबको समझ में आया ब्रूट फोर्स और
सर्वर यह वर्जन अभी तक किसी को कुछ डाउट
है सबको समझ में आ रहा
है वेरी गुड तो अभी हम क्या करते अभी यूज
करने वाले हम कौन सा मॉड्यूल यूज कर रहे
हैं ये रहा माय एल एनम एन्यूमरेशन ओके अभी
हमने क्या कर दिया इस मॉड्यूल में हमारे
पास यूजरनेम पासवर्ड है तो हमने पासवर्ड
सेट कर दिया यूजर नेम सेट कर दिया ऑप्शंस
में देखा हमने पासवर्ड यूजरनेम सेट है आरो
सेट है पोट सेट है सिंपली हमने एक्सप्लोइट
किया एक्सप्लोइट करने के बाद हमारे पास
क्या इंफॉर्मेशन आई
देखिए ओके ये रही नहीं नहीं नहीं इसको
हमने एक्सप्लोइट किया इसको रन किया तो वे
स्क्रीनशॉट वेर आई शड यूज इट मे बी आई मिस
आउट द स्क्रीनशॉट तो जैसे आप इसको यूज
करोगे नरेशन फाइंड आउट करोगे तो आपको
सर्वर इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं देगा ज्यादा
इंफॉर्मेशन आपको प्रोवाइड नहीं करेगा इसको
रन करते वक्त मैंने स्क्रीनशॉट नहीं लिया
तो आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट आप इसको रन करोगे
तो एक इंफॉर्मेशन आएगी कुछ वर्जन नंबर और
वो यह न्यूमरेशन है देन नेक्स्ट मैं यूज
करता हूं कौन
सा यह सेम ही है मे बी मे बी मे बी मे बी
मे बी माय एसकल एनम ओके
ओके ओके यह सेम ही
है सेम सेम सेम नहीं य सेट पासवर्ड फिर से
मैंने वही थोड़ा सा य पर मैंने गलती कर दी
है यू जट किया देन देन इस माय मिस्टेक यूज
सिक्स यूज सिक्स माय एसकल एनम और ओके एमस
एसल अलग है माय ए एम किया देन उसके बाद
माय एसक्यूएल यूज फॉर ट य रहा माय एल एल
नेक्स्ट मॉड्यूल मैं यूज कर रहा हूं माय
एसक्यूएल एसक्यूएल क्या करना है जो
एसक्यूएल क्यूरीज है उसके अंदर क्या कर
सकता हूं मैं अपनी क्यूरी रन करने की
कोशिश करता हूं द यूज ट फिर से मैंने क्या
किया अभी यहां पर ये है जब मैं ऑप्शंस
देखते हैं तो यहां पर जो एसक्यूएल जो
कीवर्ड आपको देखना है यहां पर आप क्या कर
सकते हो अपनी एसक्यूएल क्यूरी ऐड कर सकते
हो यहां पर कौन सी क्यूरी आ है सेलेक्ट
वर्जन ये आपको वर्जन शो करेगा देखिए यहां
पर सेट यूजर नेम सेट पासवर्ड देन इसको रन
किया तो इसने क्या बताया सेंडिंग
स्टेटमेंट सेलेक्ट वर्जन
5.5.6 1012 ये अभी मैंने क्या किया
नेक्स्ट मैंने खुद की एक एसक्यूएल
स्टेटमेंट ऐड कर दी सेट एसक्यूएल शो डेटा
बेसस अब मैं डेटाबेस की इंफॉर्मेशन जैसे
रन करूंगा इसी में रन किया तो इसने
डेटाबेस की इंफॉर्मेशन शो कर दी कैसे
इंफॉर्मेशन स्कीमा माय एसक्यूएल
परफॉर्मेंस स्कीमा अपलोड वेंडर्स
वीडियोस वेयरहाउसेस यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
इसने क्या कर दी शो कर दी क्योंकि यहां पर
मैंने खुद की एसक्यूएल क्यूरी इसके अंदर
रन की अब 100 डेटाबेस हो गया अगर मुझे
नेक्स्ट क्य रन करनी है सेट एसकल सेट डटा
बेस का नाम जैसे मैंने अपलोड को सेट किया
उसके बाद फिर उसके अंदर की मैं टेबल्स की
इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट कर सकता हूं ओके तो
इस तरीके से मैंने क्या किया माय एसकल
एसक्यूएल मॉड्यूल को यूज किया नेक्स्ट फिर
से मैं एक मॉड्यूल यूज
करूंगा माय एसक्यूएल एसक्यूएल यह रहा माय
एल स्कीमा डंप माय एल स्कीमा डंप मॉड्यूल
को मैंने यूज किया उसके बाद ये रहा यूज
नंबर फोर फोर ये रहा माय ऑक्सल स्कैनर माय
एसक्यूएल माय एसक्यूएल स्कीमा डंप फिर से
मैंने ऑप्शन ट्राई किया यह रहा डिस्प्ले
रिजल्ट ट्रू यस सेशन की रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं
है सेट करने की ये रहा पासवर्ड मैं सेट कर
दूंगा यूजर नेम सेट कर दूंगा आरओ मेरे पास
सेट है आर पोर्ट मेरा सेट है फिर से सेट
पासवर्ड सेट यूजर नेम रूट फिर से मैं रन
किया और जैसे ही मैंने रन किया इसने
स्कीमा की इंफॉर्मेशन वो शो करी देखिए
डाटाबेस नाम अपलोड्स है उसके अंदर एक भी
टेबल नहीं है डाटाबेस नेम वेंडर्स है उसके
अंदर भी एक भी टेबल नहीं है वीडियोस के
अंदर एक भी टेबल नहीं है वेर हाउस के अंदर
भी एक भी टेबल नहीं है जस्ट फॉर डमी परपस
है य सारी इतनी देखिए कितनी क्रिटिकल
इंफॉर्मेशन आपके सामने आ रही है क्योंकि
आपने यूजर नेम पासवर्ड गेट इन कर लिया और
इतनी डीप में जाकर इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग कर
सकते हो आप एवरीवन यहां तक सबको समझ में आ
रहा है कि क्या चल रहा है यह ज्यादा फास्ट
तो नहीं
है मैंने अभी तक एन्यूमरेशन में जितने भी
चाहे वो नेट हो एसएमबी हो वेब सर्वर हो
एमएस एसक्यूएल हो माय एसक्यूएल हो या
एफटीपी हो एसएसएस हो जितने भी पॉसिबल
मॉड्यूल थे जितने भी टॉप मोस्ट पॉपुलर
मॉड्यूल थे मैक्सिमम सीटीएफ में यूज किए
जाते हैं या रियल में यूज किए जाते हैं
सारे के सारे मॉड्यूस मैंने क्या है आपके
सामने रन करके दिखाए ऐसा कोई मॉडल्स नहीं
बोला कि आप रन करके देख लेना आपके सामने
स्क्रीनशॉट शो कर रहा हूं खासकर एमएसएफ के
मैं हर एक मॉड्यूल को मैक्सिमम मॉड्यूल को
आपके सामने मैंने कवर किया है
ये प्रैक्टिकली तो है यार अभी देखो
मॉड्यूस रन किए हैं मॉड्यूस के रिजल्ट है
बस अंतर इतना कि आपके सामने मैं कमांड रन
करता यह आपके सामने दो तीन पा 10 सेकंड
लेता दो तीन पा मिनट लेता देन उसके बाद
यही रिजल्ट आता चीज तो वही है बट यह
स्क्रीनशॉट्स है उनके क्योंकि मेरे पास
इनका लैब एक्सेस नहीं है मेरे पास लैब्स
नहीं है और वो जो लैब्स है वो इसमें ड्यू
टू पॉलिसी उनको वायलेट नहीं कर
सकता ओके उसके बाद देखिए हमने फिर से अभी
एक है माय एल राइबल डायरेक्टरीज को हमने
यूज किया देखो कौन सा मॉड्यूल यूज कर रहा
हूं अभी मैं यह रहा यूज ऑक्सल स्कैनर माय
ए कएल माय एसकल राइट एबल डायरेक्टरीज यह
वाला यह आपको याद हो तो यह वाला
वन अभी इस मॉड्यूल को यूज करते हैं हम और
जैसे इस मॉड्यूल को हम यूज करेंगे अभी
ऑप्शंस देखते हैं इसके देखो डीआई आर लिस्ट
इसके अंदर हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा जो
डायरेक्टरी लिस्ट है क्योंकि ये क्या
करेगा कि जितने भी डायरेक्टरीज की लिस्ट
होगी इसके अंदर जो डेटाबेस है उसको शो
करेगा उसके लिए हमें क्या एक वर्ड लिस्ट
देनी पड़ेगी यहां पर डायरेक्टरी लिस्ट के
अंदर उसके बाद ये रहा पासवर्ड सेट कर
देंगे आर ऑफ सेट कर देंगे देखो मैंने क्या
किया सेट डायरेक्टरी लिस्ट यूजर शेयर मेटा
स्प्लिट फ्रेमवर्क डाटा वर्ड लिस्ट
डायरेक्टरी टेक्स्ट मैंने एक डायरेक्टरी
सेट कर दी डिफॉल्ट डायरेक्टरी जो मेरे पास
डिफॉल्ट वर्ड लिस्ट थी उसके बाद टारगेट
आईपी वर्ड बॉस फॉल्स पासवर्ड मैंने ब्लैंक
छोड़ दिया अभी ठीक है अभी मैंने क्या किया
पासवर्ड ब्लैंक छोड़ दिया और जैसे इसको रन
करूंगा मैं अभी यहां पर कुछ खास आउटपुट
नहीं आएगा क्योंकि मैंने यहां पर एक गलती
की थी और मैं यहां पर क्योंकि मैं काफी
टाइम से कर रहा था तो हमसे भी कई बार क्या
होता है ना कि जल्दी-जल्दी में बर्न आउट
होता है तो यहां पे मैंने पासवर्ड ब्लैंक
छोड़ दिया उसके उसके बाद मैं इसको रन करता
हूं और स्क्रीनशॉट इसलिए नहीं है मैंने रन
किया नो रिजल्ट कुछ खास रिजल्ट आया नहीं
मैं यार अभी तक री चीजें थी अभी क्यों
नहीं तो अभी मैं बाद में अभी रिलाइज गा कि
मुझे यहां पर क्या है पासवर्ड सेट करना था
देन ओनली इट विल शो द रिजल्ट इट शो द
लिस्ट ऑफ डायरेक्टस व्हिच आर अवेलेबल
इसलिए वो डायरेक्टरी की लिस्ट नहीं आई थी
इसलिए मेरी मिस्टेक थी जो मुझे अभी रिलाइज
हुई है ओके तो उस तो इस तरीके से ये सारे
के सारे मॉड्यूस आप यूज कर सकते हो मैंने
जितने भी मॉड्यूल आपके सामने कवर किए हैं
वो कौन-कौन से आपको बता देता हूं मैं ने
आपके सामने यूज किया है राइट टेबल
डायरेक्टरीज मायकल हैश डंप भी आप यूज कर
सकते हो डंप करने के लिए स्कीमा डंप मैंने
आपको शो करके दिखा दिया है माय एल एनम
मैंने दिखा दिया माय एसकल लॉगइन आपको दिखा
दिया माय एसक्यूएल एसक्यूएल आपको दिखा
दिया और वर्जन यह सारी की सारी चीजें
मैंने आपको रन और परफॉर्म करके दिखा दी
परफॉर्म मतलब स्क्रीनशॉट में कि किस टाइप
का आउटपुट आपके सामने शो करया क्योंकि
देखो एक चीज ध्यान में रखना कोई भी सर्विस
अगर मिस कॉन्फिडो गी तो आपको भर भर के
इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड करेगी लाइफ में याद
रख लो य अगर वह अच्छी तरीके से कन्फर है
एडमिन ने उसको सही से कन्फर किया एज पर
पॉलिसी जैसी होनी चाहिए थी तो आपको रुला
देगी इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करने में आपको
इंफॉर्मेशन मिल ही नहीं पाएगी ठीक है यह
हमेशा याद रख लो आप इतने बर्न आउट हो
जाओगे कि सर मुझे तो को इंफॉर्मेशन मिल ही
नहीं रही क्योंकि अगर वो सही से कन्फर
होगी वनटी हो सकती है उसमें डेफिनेटली हो
सकती है कोई जीरो डी हो सकती है बट अगर वो
सही से कन्फर्ट है फिर वो आपको रुला देगी
और बिगनर को तो बिल्कुल रुला देगी आप बर्न
आउट होके छोड़ दोगे साइबर सिक्योरिटी को
बो मुझे कुछ मिल ही नहीं रहा कुछ हासिल ही
नहीं हो रहा
ओके एसक्यूएल के पैरामीटर्स हम फर्द जब हम
एसकल इंजेक्शन करेंगे ए सेल गेटन करें तब
हम फाइंड आउट कर लेंगे एल मैप भी यूज
करेंगे हम सारे काम करेंगे डोंट वरी अभी
जस्ट एन्यूमरेशन करते हैं थोड़ा सा उसके
बाद मैंने आपको दिखाया अभी ए मैप को हम
यूज कर सकते हैं य देखो ए मैप को सर्विस
वर्जन किया पोर्ट नंबर 3306 और इसने क्या
बताया पोर्ट नंबर ओपन सेम इसने इंफॉर्मेशन
प्रोवाइड की अभी कुछ लिस्ट है जो आप यूज
कर सकते हो एन मैप की स्क्रिप्ट यूज कर
सकते हो यह रही एक तो यूज कर सकते हो माय
एसक्यूएल एमटी पासवर्ड यह क्या करती है यह
चेक करती है कि क्या कोई ऐसा यूजर नेम है
जो एमटी पासवर्ड जिस पर पासवर्ड की
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है डायरेक्टली आप क्या
कर सकते हो डेटाबेस के एंटर कर सकते हो यह
स्क्रिप्ट ये चेक करती है एक ए मैप की
स्क्रिप्ट आपके सामने है माय एसक्यूएल
इंफो यह आपको इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड करने का
काम करती है एक माय एएल यूजर्स जो नंबर ऑफ
यूजर्स है कितने यूजर्स है माय एएल
डेटाबेस के उसकी लिस्ट फाइंड आउट करने के
लिए हम यूज करते हैं माय एसक्यूएल
स्क्रिप्ट उसके अंदर आर्गुमेंट प्रोवाइड
करते हैं माय एसक्यूएल रूट पासवर्ड माय
एसक्यूएल माय एसक्यूएल पास टविंकल ये उसका
पासवर्ड है देन टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस ये उस
यूजर्स की इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट क्योंकि
हमें एक्सेस है अगर डेटाबेस की इंफॉर्मेशन
चाहिए कितने डेटा बेसस है उसके अंदर तो आप
एन मैप के थ्रू भी फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो
स्क्रिप्ट के थ्रू ये रहा स्क्रिप्ट माय
एसक्यूएल डेटाबेस स्क्रिप्ट है आर्गुमेंट
प्रोवाइड करना माय एसक्यूएल इक्वल टू रूट
माय एसकल पासवर्ड इक्वल टविंकल टारगेट
आईपी एड्रेस ये आपको डेटाबेस की
इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड करेगी अब माय
एसक्यूएल के अगर वेरिएबल की इंफॉर्मेशन
फाइंड आउट करनी है और यह वेरिएबल में किस
टाइप की इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड करता है यह
आपको पता है कि कैसे मुझे चेक करना है तो
मा एसकल वेरिएबल अब इसके अंदर आपको
आर्गुमेंट कैसे प्रोवाइड करने हैं माय
एसक्यूएल यूजर्स इक्वल टू रूट माय
एसक्यूएल पास इक्वल टू ट्विंकल इस तरीके
से आप इसको यूज कर सकते हो एक स्क्रिप्ट
आप यूज कर सकते हो माय एसक्यूएल डंप हैज
इसके अंदर ससस को डंप करने के लिए आप इसको
यूज कर सकते हो जिसमें आप आर्गुमेंट कैसे
प्रोवाइड करोगे यूजर नेम इक्वल टू रूट
पासवर्ड इक्वल टू ट्विंकल देन उसके बाद आप
यूज करोगे माय एसक्यूएल ऑडिट अगर आप क्या
करना चाहते हो मेरे पूरे डेटाबेस को ऑडिट
करना चाहता हूं कि उसमें क्या-क्या वलने
बिटी कुछ एक ऑडिट एज पर पॉलिसीज के पास एक
चेक ऑफ लिस्ट होती है स्क्रिप्ट के पास कि
उसके हिसाब से पॉलिसी के हिसाब से ये सही
है या गलत है तो ये उसको ऑडिट करेगा उसके
लिए हमें क्या करते हैं आर्गुमेंट
प्रोवाइड करते हैं यूजर नेम
mysql.net यहां पर आप जहां पर सेव करना
चाहते हो उसको सेव कीजिए ऑडिट फाइल को और
टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस और उसके बाद इस फाइल
को कैट करके देख सकते हो कि एज पर चेक ऑफ
लिस्ट कहां-कहां पर मेरी कमियां है इस
डाटा टा बेस के मतलब एज पर पॉलिसी तो इसके
लिए इसके अंदर एक चेक ऑफ लिस्ट है माय
एसक्यूएल ऑडिट के अंदर ओके तो यह सारी की
सारी आपकी एन मैप की स्क्रिप्ट है जो आप
किसके केस में यूज कर सकते हो माय
एसक्यूएल के केस में इसका तो आप
स्क्रीनशॉट ही ले लीजिए कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है आप चाहो तो इसका स्क्रीनशॉट ले लीजिए
ले लीजिए स्क्रीनशॉट ले
लीजिए हो गया
स्क्रीनशॉट ओके तो उसके बाद अगर आप एमएस
एसक्यूएल एन्यूमरेशन परफॉर्म करना चाहते
हो मेरे पास एमएस एसक्यूएल का कोई भी
लैब्स नहीं था इवन मेरे प्रीमियम पे भी
नहीं था तो मेरे पास एक वर्ड लिस्ट है यह
वर्ड लिस्ट ये रहा एप की कौन-कौन सी
स्क्रिप्ट आप यूज कर सकते हो एमएस
एसक्यूएल इंफो एमएस एसक्यूएल एनटीएल एम
इंफो एमएस एसक्यूएल ब्रूट ब्रूट फोर्स
ट्राई कर सकते
हो यहां पर क्या कर सकते हो यूजर डीबी के
अंदर यूजर वर्ड लिस्ट प्रोवाइड करोगे ओके
उसके बाद पास डीबी के अंदर आप पासवर्ड
वर्ड लिस्ट ट्राई करोगे देन इसके बाद एमएस
एसकल एमटी पासवर्ड इसके अंदर भी चेक कर
सकते हो एमएस एसक्यूएल क्यूरी अगर आपके
पास अगर सक्सेसफुली एक वर्ड लिस्ट आपके
पास यूजर नेम और पासवर्ड है देन आप क्या
कर सकते हो इस स्क्रिप्ट के थ्रू अपनी
क्यूरी परफॉर्म कर सकते हो वैसे तो ए मैप
में आपको कोई क्यूरी परफॉर्म करने की
जरूरत हो नहीं सकती क्योंकि आपको एक तो ए
मैप का डेटाबेस डायरेक्टली एक होती है ना
माय एसक्यूएल कमांड उसके थ्रू भी एक्सेस
कर सकते हो उससे बहुत ही आसानी से क्यूरी
परफॉर्म कर सकते हो दूसरा एसक्यूएल मैप का
यूज करके भी आप क्यूरी परफॉर्म कर सकते हो
लेकिन आपको इमरजेंसी परपस पर अगर आप एम
काम दे रहे हो और वहां पर आपका एसक्यूएल
मैप काम ना करे और आपके पास कोई ऑप्शंस
नहीं हो और आपको इंपोर्टेंट क्वेरी
परफॉर्म करवानी तो आपको जस्ट एक चीट शीट
होनी चाहिए आपके पास एक इंफॉर्मेशन होनी
चाहिए कि मुझे हां मैं एन मैप के थ्रू भी
अपने स्क्रिप्ट रन करवा सकता हूं ओके
क्योंकि ओससीपी एग्जाम में आपको एमएसएफ
कंसोल यूज करने दिया ओनली वन टाइम एक ही
बार आप यूज कर सकते हो स्क्रिप्ट एमएस
एसक्यूएल क्यूरी ये रहा एमएस एसक्यूएल
यूजर नेम यूजर पासवर्ड प्रोवाइड यहां भी
आप सस को डंप कर सकते हो एमएस एसकल डंप फस
स्क्रिप्ट आर्गुमेंट एमएस एसक्यूएल यूजर
नेम यूजर एमएस एएल पासवर्ड इक्वल टू पास
एमएस एएल एक्सपी कमांड सेल इक्वल टू आईपी
को यहां पर क्या कर सकते हो आप कमांड रन
करने की कोशिश कर सकते हो इसके थ्रू ओके
तो ये कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट आपकी एमफ स्क्रिप्ट
ही आप रन कर सकते हो अगर इसके अंदर आप मैं
आपको बताऊं कि अगर आप एमएसएफ मॉड्यूल के
कौन-कौन से यूज़ कर सकते हो मेटा स्प्लिट
मॉड्यूस तो मैं आपको बता देता हूं वभी
लिस्ट बता देता
हूं ऑक्सल
उसके बाद
स्कैनर उसके बाद एमएस
एसक्यूएल उसके बाद है एम एस एस क्यूएल
अंडरस्कोर एक तो
लॉगिन यह इसके अंदर आप यूज कर सकते हो
दूसरी आप यूज कर सकते हो मैं इसको कॉपी कर
लेता हूं बारबार लिखना नहीं पड़ेगा
कंट्रोल सी कंट्रोल व और दूसरा आप क्या कर
सकते हो एमएस एसकल लॉगइन की जगह एमएस एसकल
एनम यूज कर सकते हो मॉड्यूल का नाम एनम
यूज कर सकते हो देन कंट्रोल व तो अगला
मॉड्यूल आप यूज कर सकते हो एमएस
एसक्यूएल
एनम उसके बाद अंडरस्कोर आप यूज कर सकते हो
एसक्यूएल अंडरस्कोर
लॉगिन यह वाला मॉड्यूल आप यूज कर सकते हो
देन उसके बाद
आप एक मॉड्यूल यूज कर सकते हो एक्सक कमांड
एग्जीक्यूट करने के लिए ई एक्स सी एजेक्ट
एमएस एसक्यूएल देन उसके बाद आप यूज कर अगर
आपको आपका एमएस एसक्यूएल डोमेन के अंदर रन
कर रहा है तो डोमेन की इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड
आउट कर सकते एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी के केस में
एमएस एसक्यूएल एनम
अंडरस्कोर डोमेन अंडरस्कोर अकाउंट्स
अंडरस्कोर अकाउंट्स तो ये चार पांच
मॉड्यूस है ऑक्सल मॉडल्स आप यूज कर सकते
हो किसके लिए एन्यूमरेशन परफॉर्म करने के
लिए तो अभी मैं इनको क्या कर देता हूं
इनका कलर हाईलाइट कर देता हूं ब्लैक यस दज
आर द और अगर मैं इनको बताऊं तो यह रहा कौन
से लास्ट से हाईलाइट करता एमएस एसक्यूएल
लॉगिन यह रहा एमएस एसकल
एनम एमएस एसक्यूएल यह रहा एनम एसक्यूएल
लॉगिन एमएस एसक्यूएल
एक्सक कंट्रोल चस कंट्रोल बी और एमएस
एसक्यूएल एनम डोमेन अकाउंट्स ओके अब यह
सारे चार पांच ये क्या है पांच मॉड्यूल आप
इसके अंदर भी यूज कर सकते हो किसके अंदर
मेटा स्ड के अंदर भी तो सबके पास शायद मैं
आपको एक इंफॉर्मेशन प्रो करने की कोशिश कर
रहा था यह चीटशीट आपको मिल जाएगी और मैं
आपको एक इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड करने की
कोशिश कर रहा था कि आप इस तरीके से यह
स्क्रिप्ट यह मॉड्यूस आप यूज कर सकते हो
और स्क्रीनशॉट के थ्रू मैंने एग्जांपल एक
अच्छे तरीके से समझाने की कोशिश की है कि
आप स्क्रिप्ट में जब इसको रन करोगे
स्क्रीनशॉट में देखोगे तो इस टाइप का आपको
आउटपुट देखने को मिलेगा तो आई होप कि शायद
सबको समझ में आ गया होगा एक बार य चीट ट
आप रिवाइज करोगे तो शायद आपको और भी
ज्यादा क्लियर हो जाएगा
बताइए आज का सेशन इतना ही था चीट चट को
मैं आपको प्रोवाइड कर दूंगा डोंट
वरी तो स्टिल एनी डाउट किसी को लगता है
मैंने अभी कट कर दिया फिर से करना क्या
स्क्रॉल और जो हमारा नेक्स्ट सेशन रहेगा
अय सिस्टम हैकिंग से स्टार्ट
करेंगे हां मैं लिंक दिन में अभी डाल
दूंगा मैं अभी कल मॉर्निंग में अपडेट हो
जाएगा और नोट्स में भी हो जाएगा
किसी कोई डाउट है एन्यूमरेशन सेशन आपका
कंप्लीट हो गया है तो किसी
को एन्यूमरेशन से रिलेटेड आपको कोई डाउट
है और आपको सबको पता कि पता है कि मैं
किसी भी सेक्शन को स्टार्ट करता हूं थोड़ा
सा एक स्टोरी बनाता हूं उस स्टोरी को
एक्सप्लेन करता हूं स्टोरी में कुछ
स्टेप्स एक्सप्लेन करता
हूं देन उसके बाद उस सेशन को मैं
प्रैक्टिकली स्टार्ट करता हूं यह मेरी एक
आदत है और यह शायद बहुत सारे जो समझने में
जिनको थोड़ी प्रॉब्लम होती है जो स्लो
कैपचर्स होते हैं उनके हिसाब से भी मैं
बनाता हूं तो जो फास्ट कैप्चर है वो तो
कहीं से भी पढ़ लेंगे बट स्लो कैपचर्स
होते हैं उनके लिए स्टोरी बनानी जरूरी
होती है इसलिए स्टोरी स्लाइड के थ्रू ही
बनाता हूं तो इसलिए क्या है कि सिस्टम
मेकिंग में स्टार्टिंग में स्टोरी क्रिएट
करेंगे और स्टोरी के थ्रू हम कंटिन्यू फिर
अपनी डिफरेंट डिफरेंट टाइप्स की वटी को
ट्राई करेंगे
किस चीज का प्रैक्टिस करने के दो तीन दिन
दीजिए बताइए मुझे
बताओ आप लोग अगर बोलोगे नेक्स्ट क्लास तो
अभी दो दिन के बाद होगी मैक्सिमम ट्राई
आपकी थर्ड डे क्लास आएगी अभी
मैक्सिमम आप मेरे को जवाइन कर चुके हो
रामा
अनुज आप जवाइन कर चुके हो आप लाइव सेशन
में आइए अभी तो असली कहानी भी स्टार्ट
होगी असली जो एथिकल हैकिंग अभी स्टार्ट
होने वाली
है क्या बोला आपने सर क्या
एनम यह समझ में नहीं क्या पूछने की कोशिश
कर रहे हो
अभी हम करेंगे डोंट वरी अभी हर थर्ड डे
क्लास लेंगे हम आई विल ट्राई कि एक क्लास
लेने के बाद दो दिन आपको टाइम दिया जाए सो
दैट की जो थोट कल पार्ट है वहां पर आपको
रिवीजन की जरूरत नहीं है और आप पर प्रेशर
नहीं रहेगा लेकिन जो प्रैक्टिकल पार्ट
रहेंगे सीटीएफ रहेंगे मैं आपको बोलूंगा
जहां तक मैं आपको रिकमेंड करूंगा कि आप
लोग मेरे साथ ट्राई मत कीजिए आप मेरे साथ
उस दिन ट्राई ना करें कर अगर मैं आप लोगों
को बोलूंगा उस दिन सिर्फ आप
देखें उस दिन सिर्फ आप देखें और देखने के
बाद वहां पर क्या साथ के साथ मैं आपसे
पूछूंगा कि बोलो अभी मैं क्या करूंगा किस
टाइप की मुझे इंफॉर्मेशन मिल रही है ओके
मुझे कौन सी कमांड रन करनी चाहिए मुझे अब
क्या करना चाहिए मैं सब आप लोगों से
पूछूंगा और कंटीन्यूअसली मैं अपने सेकंड
मॉनिटर पर आपके चैट को देखूंगा ठीक है तो
वहां से मैं आपका रिस्पांस लूंगा सही और
गलत आपको आंसर करना है डोंट हेज कि आपको
गलत कर दिया तो मे बारे में कोई क्या
सोचेगा आपको हेजिन नहीं होना है आपको
डायरेक्टली आंसर करना है आंसर गलत भी होगा
चलेगा क्योंकि आप गलत आंसर करो तभी तो सही
आपको पता चलेगा तो वहां पर आंसर करने हैं
उस दिन आप प्रैक्टिस ना करें उसके बाद
आपको दो दिन मिलेंगे ठीक है और एक लाव का
हो सकता है कई बार हमें दो क्लास लग जाए
सॉल्व करने में या तीन भी लग जाए क्योंकि
उनके बीच में जो छोटे-छोटे टॉपिक्स रहेंगे
जो आपके फंडामेंटल्स रहेंगे कि ओके कि ये
फंडामेंटल्स आपका क्लियर होना चाहिए उस
लैब के लिए तो वो फंडामेंटल साथ के साथ
मैं आपके करवाऊंगी बीपीटी के थ्रू तो हो
सकता इसलिए हो सकता है कि उस लैब को करने
में हमें दो दिन दो क्लास लग जाए एटलीस्ट
दो क्लास एटलीस्ट दो क्लास कभी कभ कोई
बड़े अगर हार्ड लैब होगी तो इजी होंगी पर
हमें अपने तरीके से डेवलप करने में अगर
तीन लग जाए तो चिंता आपको करने की जरूरत
नहीं है बस आपका काम क्या है फिर जैसे
सेशन एंड हो जाएगा उसके बाद आपके पास जो
दो दिन रहेंगे क्या एक दिन रहेगा उसमें आप
क्या करो वो प्रैक्टिस करो और आपको क्या
करना है कि जो मैंने रन करके दिखाया वो
नहीं है सिर्फ आपके पास ध्यान में रखना कि
मैंने ओके यहां पर क्या कांसेप्ट बताया है
क्या टेक्निक्स बताई है क्या टूल यूज किया
है आपको डायरेक्टली क्या करना अगर आप कहीं
पर स्टक हो रहे हो तो ही हेल्प लो लेक्चर
की अदर वाइज आपको क्या करना है ब्लाइंड
उसको परफॉर्म करना ओके ए मैप की स्क्रिप्ट
मुझे रन करनी चाहिए क्योंकि अभी तक के
नोट्स आपके पास है उसके बाद साथ के साथ
मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन करूंगा तो उसको
ब्लाइंड आपको खुद के टेक्निक से उसको
सॉल्व करना है और एक लैब को अगर आप
मल्टीपल टेक्निक से सॉल्व कर सकते हो तो
दिस इज द बेस्ट
वे कहां पर ट्राई करोगे लान के
साथ हां रामा जी आपको नोट्स चाहिए तो आपको
सिंपली सबसे पहले एक सिंपल प्रोसेस है
आपको डायरेक्टली गो टू अवर डे फोनिक्स
देखो डेनिस अकेडमी
क्लिक ऑन द लिंक गो टू अकेडमी
टैब गो टू फ्री
रिसोर्सेस दिस वन डीई एई सर्टिफिकेट नोट्स
क्लिक हियर
एंड गेट दिस कोर्स पे ओनली जस्ट ₹1 लाइफ
टाइम एक्सेस सारे रिसोर्सेस आपको एक्सेस
रहेंगे और मैं इसको थोड़ा सा भी मुझे टाइम
मिल जाएगा एक बार मैं इसको अपग्रेड करने
वाला हूं एक बार देख लीजिए मैं इसको क्या
करूंगा अपग्रेड करूंगा इसमें मैं कुछ अभी
तक जो क्या किया है ना मैंने कि जितने भी
प्रैक्टिकल्स करवाए हैं उन प्रैक्टिकल्स
का अगेंस्ट रेफरेंस लैब मैं क्या कर फाइंड
आउट करूंगा जो फ्री लैब्स होंगी उनके
रेफरेंसेस इसके अंदर ऐड कर दूंगा सो दैट
कि आप वहां पर फ्री में प्रैक्टिस कर पाओ
हर एक टॉपिक के हिसाब से क्योंकि मैंने
बताया कि मेटा स्लट 3 मैंने यूज किया है
बट आप हो सकता कि आप यू आर इनकैपेबल टू
सेट अप योर लैब्स बिकॉज ऑफ कॉन्फिन ऑफ योर
पीसी इसका भी मैं सलूशन जल्दी इसके अपडेट
कर दूंगा सो दैट की आप हर एक पार्ट वाइज
इसको क्लियर कर पाए अभी मैं जो प्लानिंग
सोच रहा था क्योंकि अभी अगर स्टूडेंट्स
ज्यादा
आएंगे अगर स्टूडेंट्स ज्यादा आएंगे तो
फिर तो मैं फिर ट्राई कर सकता हूं देखो
लाइव सेशन में जितने ज्यादा स्टूडेंट्स
आएंगे तभी मैं फर्द जो ₹1 वाला सीन है
उसको लेके मैं क्या कर सकता हूं
तो मैं उसको प्लान नहीं करूंगा क्योंकि
एटलीस्ट मुझे यहां पर youtube1 आना
स्टार्ट हो जाओ मैं उे प्लान कर लूंगा
क्योंकि यहां पर 100 नहीं आएंगे तो मैं
यार क्योंकि उसपे क्या है ना मेरी कन्फेशन
पूरी कंज्यूम हो जाएगी मेरे को कितनी
मशीने यूज करनी पड़ेगी यू डोंट नो क्योंकि
मुझे
ओके तो सेशन को एंड
करें फिल्म आपका सवाल है ना जो सर माय
एसक्यूएल से एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन अटैक
परफॉर्म कर सकते हैं क्या मैं आपका सवाल
नहीं समझ अब एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन बताइए पहले
क्या होता है
बताइए एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन होता क्या है आप
ही बताइए पहले आप जो सवाल पूछ मेरे ख्याल
से आप खुद कंफ्यूज पूछना क्या चाह रहे
हो ओके सेशन को एंड करते हैं फिर ओके अगर
किसी कोई डाउट डाउट नहीं है
तो ओके ओके थैंक यू हैप्पी न्यू ईयर यू
आल्सो हैप्पी न्यू एडवांस
ओके थैंक यू एंड बाय बाय और फिर सी यू फॉर
नेक्स्ट सेशन गुड नाइट एंड टेक केयर ओके
तो अभी हम नेक्स्ट सेशन में मिलते हैं
जल्दी मिलेंगे और अपनी सिस्टम हैकिंग की
जर्नी के साथ स्टार्ट करते हैं आई
रिक्वेस्ट एटलीस्ट
अब तो स्टूडेंट्स को ले आइए अब ऐसा मत
करना कि सर अभी 30 स्टूडेंट है उसमें
मुझसे सच में बर्दाश्त नहीं होगा कि
सिस्टम हैकिंग में भी अगर आप बंदे नहीं आ
पा रहे हैं इतने इंपोर्टेंट टॉपिक्स में
भी बंदे नहीं आ पा रहे हैं तो फिर शायद ही
सबका फॉल्ट है क्योंकि फिर आप बंदे नहीं
लेकर आ
पाते ओके तो बाय बाय टेक केयर थैंक यू एंड
गुड नाइट